[Music]
six months after the attack on the
capitol on january 6
many americans believe our democracy is
in trouble only 21
in a recent quinnipiac university
national poll say our democracy
is alive and well while 70 say it's
under threat
60 percent in a mid-june economist yukov
poll said they were dissatisfied with
the way democracy was working
and in a separate question in the poll
41
said that they were pessimistic about
democracy's future here
january 6 still reverberates in the
minds of many americans
and 55 percent in another quinnipiac
poll said the attack on the capital
should never be forgotten
39 in this may 2021 poll
said that too much was being made of it
and it was time to move on
while america's short-term confidence in
u.s democracy is still
shaken 69 percent in a pew research
center poll
say they have confidence in the future
of the u.s and 54
in an ap north pole say america's best
days are ahead
[Music]
what do you think about the state of
american democracy let us know on our
poll
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from aei